fire base makes basic user
authentication very easy but what
happens if you require additional data
from your user before they're authorized
to start using your app in this episode
I'm going to set up a multi-step signup
form that requires the user to fill out
a catchphrase on their user profile
before they're authorized to start using
the app then we're going to secure all
the application data on both the front
end and the back end this feature works
by setting up a custom user document in
the firestore database we can then
verify that the current user has the
correct information on their document
before they're authorized to perform
certain actions in order to build this
feature I'm going to be using the fire
starter demo app which is on github you
can clone it if you want but this code
can be applied to any angular app that's
using firebase but before we get started
make sure to subscribe and you can find
all the source code at angular firebase
com the first place we're going to start
is in the auth service and in my case
it's in that core module the goal with
the service is to keep track of the
current user and give them the ability
to sign in via email and password the
important imports to take note of here
are angularfire auth and angular fire
store as well as the switch map operator
from rxjs the first thing I'm going to
do is set up an interface to model our
user data we need to have a user ID and
email address which we'll get from
firebase auth and then our custom piece
of data is the catchphrase notice that
you don't need to actually add the
password to the user interface that's
all handled by angularfire auth so our
actual user is going to be an observable
type to this interface then we'll inject
our dependencies in the constructor the
notify service that I'm adding here is
part of the demo app it's not required
but it's used to show the end-user any
problems with the sign-in process then
inside the constructor we'll define the
user variable so we do this by calling
angularfire auth state which gives us an
observable that we can call switch map
on if the current user is logged in then
we'll go ahead and retrieve the user
data from fire store we do that by
calling AFS doc and then point to that
current users user ID and then call
value changes to get the observable if
the users not logged in then we're just
going to return an observable up null
that chunk of code is going to keep
track of the current user at the global
level throughout our application it's
easy for things to go wrong with email
password
for example the user might try to login
with an email address that's already
been taken when that happens we're going
to use this helper method to notify the
user in the front-end after that we're
going to create another helper method
that will create a new user document
when the user first signs up when the
user signs up firebase will give us a
user object we can then use that object
to point to a document in fire store at
this point we're only going to have the
user's email address and user ID so
we'll go ahead and set that to an object
then we can update the document in fire
store now we need a way to create a new
user by having that blog in with an
email address and a password so we'll
create a method that will handle this
data and then we can call angularfire
auth create user with email and password
this is going to return a promise and if
it's successful it will return the user
object and then we'll go ahead and use
that user object to create the user
document in that helper method that we
just defined and lastly we'll catch any
errors and notify the user if there's
any problem with the signup that handles
the first part of the signup but if you
have additional steps you'll need a
method to update data on that user
document this method will take the
current user as well as the data that we
want to update and then we'll point to
that users user ID and fire store and
update the data now let's jump over to
the user form component and put the
service to use first I want to show you
how it's set up in the router so here
I'm in the app routing module and I have
three unrelated components that we're
going to lock down for unauthorized
users later and then our user form
component we're going to load at the
login path we're going to come back here
a little bit later to add a router guard
to secure all of these routes then
you'll also need to go into whichever ng
module uses this component and import
the reactive forms module from angular
forms now we can start writing this
component first we need the off service
and we also need a few reactive forms
pieces including form group form builder
and validators the component is going to
use two separate form groups so the
first form will be the signup form and
the second form will be the detail form
where we collect any additional
information we want from the user in
this case we're only collecting that
catchphrase property but you could
collect any information you want there
then we'll inject form builder in the
constructor as well as the aw service to
create a reactive form you call form
builder group and then you pass it an
object where each key is a corresponding
form field so in this case we have an
email input then we set its value equal
to an array where the first value in
that array is an empty string and then
the second value is another array of
validators these validators are based on
their HTML counterparts in this case we
are going to validate the email is
required and that it has an email format
for the password we're going to use a
regular expression which just validates
that there's at least one number present
in that password string and then we're
also going to validate that it has a
minimum length of 6 and a max length of
25 then we'll set up the second form in
exactly the same way but it's actually
much simpler we'll just say detail form
is the form builder group and its only
field is going to be the catch phrase
which is required and that's all it
takes to set up a reactive form it's
just a series of form fields that are
defined directly in your type script the
main problem is that they generally
create a lot of typescript code so we
can cut down on this code at least a
little bit by using getters so we'll
call signup form get email and we'll
repeat this pattern for each individual
form field when we get to the actual
form HTML you'll see that this
drastically cuts down on the amount of
code that we need to use in the template
the last thing we need is an event
handler for when these forms are
submitted so when they submit the signup
form we'll call our email signup method
from the service with their email value
and password value and for the
catchphrase we simply call the off
service update user method with the
catch phrase that they enter into that
form now we're going to switch over to
the HTML and I'll show you how to use
this reactive form in the template I'm
going to set up an NG container that's
going to wrap both of the forms the
reason for this is that we can unwrap
the user observable to apply some
conditional logic to determine which
form to show so we'll do that by calling
auth user async or we're going to show
an empty object if the user is null and
then we're going to set that to the user
template variable
I realize that looks kind of weird but
it is a very useful technique in angular
the next thing we'll do is set up our
forum group so we do that by calling
forum group with our signup form this
forum should only be shown if we don't
have a user ID meaning the user has no
firebase account at all then I'm going
to add the detail forum right below it
and we're only going to show this forum
if the user is authenticated but they
still don't have that catchphrase on
their user document then I'll set up one
more block here and this one will show
if the user is logged in and they have a
catch phrase meaning that forum is 100%
complete you could extract this into
separate components but I'm just showing
it all in one go here just to keep this
as simple as possible going back to the
signup form will first find our signup
method to the ng submit event then we'll
set a label and a form input for the
email address we connect this input to
our reactive form in the type script by
calling form control name followed by
email because we set validators on this
form we can determine whether or not it
is in a valid state based on the user's
input when the form is not valid we want
to show an error message and we only
want to show it if the form is dirty
which means that the user has started
typing into that form input then we'll
go and do the same exact thing for the
password but the only difference instead
of dirty here I'm going to use touched
the form input is considered touched
when the user has entered their mouse
inside of that form input so that just
gives you another option for determining
when you want to actually display the
error message we can also tell when a
form is valid by calling signup form
valid we can determine if the entire
form is valid as well as all the inputs
contained inside of it as a final touch
we'll disable the submit button so the
user can't accidentally submit an
invalid form when the user submits their
form and they're successfully
authenticated it's going to hide this
initial form and then bring up our
secondary form here so for this one
we'll bind it to the set catchphrase
method and then we'll go ahead and add
the form control name and then another
submit button for that as well the end
result looks something like this we
start typing in the form and then we get
this validation error until we actually
enter a valid email then it has the
green border then we go ahead and enter
our password and we get the green
message that the form looks good so now
we ought then takeda in firebase and
then it brings up the secondary form the
process works as expected at this point
but we still want to set up a router
guard to prevent our users from
navigating away from the forum if they
haven't fully completed it we can do
that by setting up an auth guard that
we'll use in our app routing module
guards use the injectable decorator so
they behave just like services do an
angular first I'm going to import it
into the module and then add it to the
providers array then you can use the
guard on individual routes by setting
the can activate property and you just
pass it to its array of guards now we
can go into the actual auth card file
and we're going to import our auth
service and if you remember from earlier
our off service provides a user
observable so what we're going to do is
convert that user observable into a
boolean that's going to determine
whether or not a user is authorized to
visit a certain route so we're going to
inject the off service in the
constructor and then we're going to use
the angular router as well as the
notification service that I was talking
about earlier the can activate method
inside the guard needs to return a
boolean observable so we first take our
user observable and then we map it down
to a boolean and we determine this
boolean by whether or not the user has
that catch phrase property on their user
document we convert the property to a
boolean by adding a double bang in front
of it if this evaluates to false we're
going to use the router as well as the
notification service to redirect the
user back to the form and then show them
an error message the end result is that
any routes that have this guard applied
to it will not be activated unless the
user has that catch phrase property on
their document in fire store that's only
going to secure routes on the front end
if you have truly sensitive information
there you'll want to also send a back
end database rule in this case you can
check if the catch phrase exists on the
current users document by pointing to
the user document with the request auth
UID
if it's not there the user won't be able
to read or write any documents
associated with this rule
that's it for a multi-step
authentication with firebase if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to learn more
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get a free
copy of my book as well as one on one
project support thanks for watching and
I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]